我侵赤游道其实真的可以通过互乎来说像盲控的
因为我自己的举个盲控就是这么说小的
但这个流程不管是那种因为
游质和迷万物圣产生的盲控出大
还说因为交流流石导致的盲控下层
它都可以改善
而且是一般我做完第二天就可以看到效果
但是不是说你第二天盲控就没了
这个是不可能的
第二天早上赵静子的时候
我会发现我的盲控
它是呈现一个收紧的一个状况
它们都是整齐排列的
像盲控里面的那些小涛起小颗里都没有了
整个皮膚看起来就是很平滑
那坚实做的话这个盲控就会把它给你回收回来了
第一步我们现在解决最好处理的因为游质和迷万物圣
导致的大盲控
我们首先用一个这种游质导出一夜
来打开我们的皮膚通道
我一般会把它服在我那种爱出游盲控大的地方
你这两车下还发的那种颗粒
这一步是为了把盲控的门打开
这样子我们后续的甜盲控的一样品才能不进去
风的时候可以再加一个热盆
就帮助打开这个盲控头打
热盆的话盆十分钟就可以了
好现在我们来看时产油脂口
就是这些油脂平时把盲控堵住了
把我们盲控撑着
越来越大
就是让我们的点开起来非常不透亮
你凸什么货富品进去
你都感觉吸收不了啥
好的
我起碗练了
现在我们再用一个酸洞某在我们的
像这层后碗油脂多的地方
再来一个二次食通
彻底的打开皮不通道
这一步对那种成年
油脂肚三产生的盲控
非常非常有用
因为我们刚刚清完的盲控
马上就用酸的话
它除了能够疏痛盲控之外
还可以加速我们的老肺脚住的担心
这一步还是要避开明明的地方
因为像我们的盲控
它其实是一个原株型
我们这个最外面的这一层是这个盲控最大的部分
我们用酸去把它担心掉
让我们比面嫩嫩的皮肤就会出来了
所以我们的盲控会看起来就用小了一些
好
现在我复得两分钟
我就洗个脸
好人好人
现在我刚显然人
皮肤变得非常非常光滑
目前没有用柯力感
我每一个盲控都在大口呼吸
现在就到了我们收盲控
最关键的时期
很多姐妹平时只是说做清节
但是没有注意后序的呼服
那这样你就错过了我们甜盲控的最佳时期
刚刚我们把盲控清节干净之后
现在盲控力量
它是一个中空的状况
这个时候我们马上补金去一些能够支撑皮肤的东西
盲控就不会因为失去支撑
这也是我的这个松脑口的流程的精彩所在
清完就补的效果
你们适过一次之后
你就知道有多经验了
那我一般补的就是我最爱的这个教员胖
就老本知道我都爱他爱的非常疯狂
这个是我目前用到五姜圆方面
最有效果的精彩
是真的可以让我感觉皮肤变得丰盈
软嫩很多
我一般做完这种清节中会图亮死
再上一次
而且这种税状的之底
那他们家用的都是市面上
非常小分子的教员
所以我会感觉一上约秀的一下
就全部都洗上进去了
非常非常清爽
我这半年以来
我大概是用了个二三十平
真的是肉严可见的
让我的这个毛控变小
变细致
而且我的面中整个会感觉
更封与更保满了
那用他来搭配我的这个松脑口的流程
教员直播的话
就可以让我的松脑控一起
开腰的效率都更高
像我以前松脑口的是没有去补教员的
但是我发现自从二十五家之后
我们脸上的毛控
他会呈现一个符合状
既有被油脂沉耐的毛控
又有教员流失导致的这种
呈下垂状控的毛控
那这种毛控
你只做经济的
完全不够的
因为教员流失
他会让毛控
被拉长
被拉成那种水滴形
肉眼看起来非常的鲜腦形状
不教员呢
就是给我们的每一个毛控
周围的皮膚加固
把他从一个松垮了
他长的状况
撑毁更紧是
更接近原形的健康形态
那世界上就会看起来
感觉皮膚吸引很多
所以清潔
它是让我的毛控
疏通不堵
那补教员
是让我的毛控不快
这两个必须搭遍起来
我们的毛控才能够
真正的越来越小
现在应该我脸上的这个
教员跑已经洗手碗了
我会再加上
一个他们家的这个重够面爽
来共顾我这个不教员的效果
那他们家的这个面双
膚感很激引
薄薄的头一层
被脸上按摩
让这个教员跑的影响
以及这个面双的影响更好的
被我们的毛控
是进去
那我这个很喜欢
就是你看起来感觉
它好像很厚
但是它图在脸上
就会像那种
耐双一样
瞬间就画开在我们的脸上
而且这面说
吸收碗了之后
我们的整个皮膚
是呈现一个很感受的一个状况的
就是既能感受
当这种贵膚面爽的膚感
和脂肖
但是有完全不会有蜜后种
好现在我再加一个面膜
来加一样
把我们的影量全部都给它对应去
大概风格十分钟都可以
那我们今晚上脸上的这些教员
更好的
被皮膚吃进去
好了 现在时间到了
来把面膜摘下来
看完之后
我们可以再给它按摩一下
让皮膚把这些影量全部都给吃进去
眼周也可以按
其实这个时候
你比较真很确实
很确实
做一个这种提外的按摩
我们不用去洗脸了
我们这晚上就用这种
大师的洗脸金
把脸上的这些
没有吸收碗的
你那给
它按掉就行了
现在我们在来
后续的互风
依旧是一帮教员跑
图正张脸
眼周不要放过
我后续再用一个毛孔精华
它是酸A一起的
非常的高养
因为今天晚上我现在要
直到双方口的效果
更不梦理解
再加一个清爽的
用双作一个风盘
就可以了
我还是用的这个成功面爽
现在我们就可以去睡觉了
给它一个晚上的
深度吸收时间
第二天早上起床的皮膚状态
一上睡宝了
10个小时的教员
没有任何反腦
用去做了一个高级護理的感觉
毛孔
非常非常吸引